cortez is accusing people of using
racist language for calling the increase
of migrants at the border a
surge anyone who's using the term
surge around you consciously
is trying to invoke a militaristic frame
this is not a surge these are children
and they are not insurgents and we are
not being
invaded which by the way is a white
supremacist
idea philosophy
but aoc's words are conflicting with the
reality on the ground border patrol
officials are warning the situation is
spiraling out of control
the capacity for this location for covet
purposes is 250. we're holding over
4 100 subjects in this location alone
so you do the math we're way over
capacity we're like 700
over capacity based upon what we've
already apprehended
and looking at what's remaining in in
the fiscal year that we will have
approximately about a million
apprehensions or encounters this year
jesse i was thinking of bringing my
merriam webster's dictionary with me to
the set today
because serge that's a verb
that the biden administration itself has
been using
about the number of children that are
arriving or migrants that are arriving
in addition they're saying they are
surging
resources into the region so i don't
know if it's the word so much but
this is pretty clever way to distract
from the fact that she is
not calling the biden administration out
for keeping kids in cages as she did for
the trump administration
i'd ask her to open her eyes there's a
surge of sunnis
going into turkey right now there's a
surge of near east
migrants going into the far east there's
a surge of african migrants
going into other african nations right
now happens all over the world
has been from the beginning of time and
the local media in those places cover it
and they use the word search white
supremacy has nothing to do with that
let's paint a hypothetical situation
let's say 20
000 white minnesota teenagers americans
were surging into canada each month
and during a pandemic and they were
undercutting wages and they were
crowding up already overcrowded schools
do you think canada would build more
beds and start busing them into nova
scotia
no they in their ca polite canadian way
would say sorry the border is closed or
if
russians were crossing the bering strait
into alaska
america would say yet no the border is
closed has nothing to do with race at
all
this has something to do with
controlling our own immigration policy
it's based on our choices and what's
beneficial to
our citizens birth rate economy
asylum requests joe's turned it upside
down
now it's the cartel and the migrants
choice when to come
where to come and how many are coming
it's not our choice anymore and that's
not
a civilized modern way to run a
sovereign nation's immigration policy
geraldo let's get your take on this
well i don't like the militaristic
characterizations
jesse who i held in the highest regard
and i have had
uh clashes on this issue before to talk
about the the invasion of the migrants
or the columns of the
uh my numbers coming up you really put
it in
we put it in uh we and i you and i who
can pull the tape
have had you know we've butted heads
about it
the point is through a combination of
naivete and
arrogance and and you know uh his own
uh you know uh feel and compassion for
these people
joe biden has created a crisis on the
border it is a crisis
he has lured these people where the hell
is the mexican army why didn't the
mexican army stop them
in the guatemalan border the way they
did during the trump administration
this is an error maybe it came from a
position of love but it's a terrible
mistake that the blind administration
made and now it has to be undone
but these children when there's a
five-year-old you've seen this video
a five-year-old a seven-year-old some
even younger
and they're unaccompanied and they're
coming into the united states it's full
stop
it's not about geopolitics it's not
about anything
other than america has to take care of
these weak and vulnerable children
that's our role that's our
responsibility and to speak of them in
anything other than a human rights
context is really something that i think
violates our own best principles we are
better than that the united states is
better than that i'm not saying we have
open borders for the whole world but for
god's sakes
let's take care of these kids and then
deal with the bigger problem of stopping
the flow
from uh you know uh impoverished central
america
megan um you want to watch that
uh alexandra ocasio-cortez video again
because that's what desperation looks
like
if you ever need a reminder this is what
this is the best that she could come up
with
to try and shut down the conversation
because her team is deliberately putting
children in harm's way it's bad for them
as geraldo pointed out
this is a heinous unforgivable
catastrophe putting children and
families and
you know border patrol workers border
communities at risk
this is a national and humanitarian
crisis
of joe biden's making and this is the
best
language or distraction that
ocasio-cortez could come up with
trying to shut people up by calling them
white supremacists
it's a pathetic attempt at trying to
stop people talking about what everyone
can see
last word to you brian my last word is
this i'm disappointed
i'm disappointed in her she's the lazy
way out white supremacist it's been nine
seconds and we haven't used that term
she's the woman that took on the speaker
she's the woman that said only in
america can i belong to the same party
as joe biden now she sees these pictures
that are 700 of these kids 700 percent
over capacity the only thing different
between these and the ones she
disliked so much under president trump
which are actually more president
obama's
well their soft sides their pens instead
of being surrounded by fences to keep
them away from adults
this is out of control they've moved
them over to san diego where nine
percent of them are positive of the
coronavirus
this is her time to be above it all and
say what she and be consistent
and to be consistent aoc consistent
would be to call
out president biden for not even having
the wherewithal to go to the border and
see
the mess he caused and make his vice
president do the job he asked him to do
she had a chance to be above it instead
she plays politics
and blames white people lazy
disappointing
and uh i she got herself if her goal was
to get headlines to get people to
talking
success substance failure
yep she can do that